you you can have sex right of course
like I'm I'm not going to sit here tell
you what you can and can't do but if you
let's say I don't I don't know your
personal opinion let's say like you
really don't like the idea of having
abortion you said to yourself if you was
that 1% that was taking contraception
religiously you never missed a pill you
did everything right and you got
pregnant you said you'd be humanin does
that not indicate to you that you're
having sex with people that you probably
wouldn't want to have children with so
therefore shouldn't you be only having
sex with people that you would see
yourself having a child with otherwise
you're being negligent to that life that
would then be here